hi guys my name is Heinrich and welcome
to another coffee break with firm
learning today I'd like to talk about
the little things the little things that
may not seem important at first sight
but can really make a difference how you
are perceived in your work environment
personally I like to call these things
hygiene factors so if you wonder what a
hygiene factor is let's think about a
great hotel it is super luxurious a
great entrance hall you have a personal
Butler who brings you your food your
luggage and everything else you may need
so at first hand it might seem that this
is just an amazing experience and a
great hotel to be it and actually
imagine the following thing you're going
to the bathroom and you'll find the
toilet not being cleaned their hairs of
potentially previous guests in your
shower and it just does not seem clean
and nice as you would expect what would
be the impression of this hotel now well
for sure never mind all the great butler
services and luxurious wines and great
luxurious entrance oils your experience
your impression of that hotel will be
offered and this is you to something
that is called hygiene factors these are
factors that if they are there by
themselves they do not make a great
impression but if they're not there any
more of their gun then this is super bad
and your customer your professional your
work colleague will just have a very bad
impression of you just as the hygiene
and hotel hotel may be as great as this
might be but if the toilet the bathroom
is not hygienic then it's just a barrel
tear right and there are similar things
like that in the workplaces where there
are these little things that if you do
them that by itself will not be great
nobody will say hey this Tony guy is so
great because he's doing these things
right but if you don't do them then that
actually might be perceived as
unprofessional as not knowing the rules
of the game it's just not being part of
the culture it's just not knowing how to
behave in a go-ahead and professional
manner and you don't want that right so
let's go over five things like that
there are little things but I believe
really make a difference and these are
some lessons that I really learned from
my time at McKinsey where these things
are
just perceived to be super basic you
just need to follow these kind of
professional standards but this is not
just too dieting this is true for
other industry firms like that where
these things are just important and you
do not want to stand out by not doing
these things right so let's start with
five tips that really make a difference
in the workplace and that you should
just get right in order to not be
perceived in a negative way the first
tip is about how you write your emails
and let me start with a little story
here a friend of mine recently started
working with a large venture capitalist
fund here in Germany and he told me the
story and I just thought it was funny so
let me just share it right because when
he was kind of applying for the job and
getting his first interviews of course
the tone was super friendly he was
writing this emails and getting these
super nice and friendly responses and so
on and then suddenly after he got hired
and kind of he wrote the very first
email in the same style he was always
writing them and the first reply he got
from this direct supervisors please and
let's just call this guy Tony please
Tony from now on only and bullet points
I only want to have even it's important
points right and and this sound might
sound a bit stupid and ridiculous but I
think this is really to the point an
important in work life nobody wants to
read through paragraphs of text of lots
and lots of words of super long email of
a page and longer and so on nobody wants
to read these kind of emails if you
write an email make sure that it's
written in bullet points at least always
if it goes kind of beyond a couple of
sentences right but if you have several
thoughts that you want to share never
just write text but write it in bullet
points each bullet punch and consists of
one argument one thought one point that
you want to bring forward be concise be
to the point don't write fluff in your
emails make it crisp and clear what you
want and this is just helpful to
everybody because otherwise you are just
a waste of time right nobody wants to do
that nobody wants to read these kind of
super limits my second tip also regards
to emails but not what you write them
them but rather documents attachments
that you do what you see super
frequently in businesses the people are
sending around attachments with the name
of something like copy of copy of
five da-da-da-da-da blah blah blah XLS
or something like that right so baby you
have an attachment with a name that has
just not been edited that just has been
exported copied from whatever other
program and you don't have a clue at all
what is in the attachment just by
reading the name guys this is just super
unprofessional you cannot retract that
you cannot just send these attachments
with these gibberish names like that
right
I mean imagine all these people needing
to drag-and-drop your attachment maybe
in their file structure and their file
system and all the need for us to look
into it and then to give it a name
how much more convenient would it be to
everybody if just you from the beginning
would have given a clear and crisp name
to that attachment that basically the
person would directly know what is in
the file but then could just drag the
file in his own side system without
needing to edit it or do any other
changes to the file name be professional
name your attachments in a way that
makes sense guys otherwise it's just
unprofessional don't do that don't be
that guy do it this way and you'll be
fine just fine third point is about your
availability and here of course the
culture might be different from business
to business so this may be not relate to
your specific business to your specific
organization but from my experience this
is something that is just very well
received and widely appreciated and
Situationists are you available if your
colleague your team leads your
supervisor or another person you work
with wants to reach out to you right and
especially if your phone and personally
in my organization where I currently
work I know two or three people if I try
to call them I just know that they will
not pick up at that moment right they
are just not available on the phone I
will not be able to know just call them
and reach them and this is just annoying
right maybe I just want to talk about
something with them I would like to
discuss a thought I have there's
something maybe super urgent and
important I'd like to address but these
people are just not approachable and
that's a problem and in organizations
would usually tend to happen is that
these people actually are called less
frequently than others they are
considered less
than other colleagues if I want to know
something want to discuss something I
rather call the guy who I know would
pick up right and will let me know
what's going on and if he has some time
for me or maybe later but if you are the
guy who never picks up his phone
maybe even doesn't want to because if
it's bothered feels like this is not the
best use of my time or whatever you know
I would just don't reach out to these
people anymore
and in the long term and the short term
this might be nice helpful you might
feel like you have more time to be or
other things but in the long term this
will really hurt your reputation and
your standing organization so do not do
that and what I would advise always make
sure if somehow possible to pick up and
if you do not have time at the moment
just let the guy know sorry right now is
not a good time let me call you later
let's call this evening let's have a
call tomorrow or if you really cannot
pick up the phone right now then at
least directly write a short text and
say sorry can't talk right now we call
you later right but we responsive answer
let the other person know what is going
on and how she can reach you because
usually if somebody calls you there's
something important that the person
wants to discuss so don't just flake
right don't just talk away from the call
but take it and make sure you're
reachable for the important people in
your organization the fourth tip is
about how you handle meetings and
meeting invites and sure this might also
depend on the organization it may be at
your place it's very different than some
rates but usually what what I observe
what is widely appreciated and almost
all organizations is making good use of
calendar invites of your Outlook invite
calendar system or the the iCloud system
or whatever you might use right but make
use of that so if you have a meeting
make it a good habit of yours of always
sending out a calendar invite to make
sure that that person directly has it in
their calendar because usually what
would happen and this person who needs
to make the invite the entry in the
calendar or himself which of course
takes time and is annoying and
especially if you're hosting larger
meetings made with more than only one
counterpart and every person needs to do
that by himself
instead of you just doing it once and
then everybody has a diary key in the
calendar right and of course there are
other benefits too
as well if you reschedule everybody
directly sees it what you should of
course also do is always enter a
location right if it's kind of out of
office enter the exact address where the
other person is supposed to go don't
just enter the name of the hotel or the
name of the conference room that you
would like to go to because it's just
very annoying and completely
unprofessional if the person just find
that and then needs to look it up on
Google or somewhere else just to know
where you actually intend to meet right
and especially you know imagine a
situation where you sit in a car maybe
have your phone connected to the
navigation system you expect that the
invite has this info you click on your
calendar you open the invite and then
just to find that you cannot just click
on the address and it really guide you
in the navigation to go there which you
would have expected and you wouldn't
have hope for but now that you just find
a name of or tear that know you need to
independently good and look out for I
mean again guys this is annoying this
unprofessional don't be that guy don't
do that always send out invites to make
it easier for everybody who's supposed
to participate and then also make sure
that all the relevant meeting
information is actually included in this
invite to make the life easier for
everybody who's involved now to my tip
number five and this is about how you
actually handle meetings and one thing
that I believe is really crucial but
that many people don't do setting up
proper agendas if you set up a meeting
if you invite somebody maybe even just
the colleague you would like to talk to
you about few topics always make sure
that in the inviting the email that you
write him in advance they are kind of in
a bullet style format the things that
you would like to talk to the things
that you would like to address you know
meetings are just super annoying if
there's an invite nobody really knows
what it's supposed to be all about
nobody has an understanding what the
outcomes are supposed to be of the
meeting and then you're sitting in the
meeting with the meeting organizer and
often even the organize I'm self hasn't
clearly thought that out and then very
often these meetings are just completely
unproductive so again please do your
very best to prepare let the other
person know what the meeting is supposed
to be
on the board to also give the other
person a chance to prepare for himself
right because then the likelihood of the
meeting being a success and yielding
results that are valuable for everybody
and being a good investment of time for
everybody involved are just much higher
do that and everybody will be happy and
you will just create a much more
professional experience in your
organization so let me just recap five
tips today little tips little things
where I believe though that these things
really make a difference first is about
how you write emails make sure that they
and the bullet forum type right bullet
points don't write long text nobody
wants to read long email second point
make sure that you name your attachments
properly the people can just pick up the
attachment know what's in can directly
store it in the whole file system
without any trouble anything that's just
kind of annoying and nobody knows what's
in there third tip is your availability
make sure that people can reach you if
you're calling pick up or at least write
a short text letting the person know
that right now is not a bad but not a
good time but you of course happy to
reach out later be available to the
important people in your organization
fourth is about how you handle meeting
invites make sure that you always send
such an invite and make sure that all
the relevant information is included in
it especially the location of course
also for instance dialing information
for telecom telephone conference or
anything like that and last but not
least meeting agendas if you talk to
somebody set up a meeting with an
individual or group make sure that you
let know the people in advance what is
expected of them what the agenda is what
you hope to get out of the meeting five
things you may believe these only little
things and you're right they are and
probably if you do that it's not like
everybody will walk around and say this
Tony guy is the greatest guys of all
right but if you don't do these things
with a high likelihood this will fall
back negatively on you it's like a
hygiene factor it's like the toilet that
is not cleaned up properly get that
right and make a good thing out of that
thank you guys thank you not so guys
thank you for watching this new episode
of firm learning if you enjoyed it I
would very much appreciate if you could
just subscribe here below to the channel
I have many more content pieces lined up
for the next weeks and month
would love you to be there and listen to
that of course if you have any comments
any feedback let me know also write in
the comment section below I'd love that
have a good day and thank you for
watching